I started in Mainframe development long
time ago might be 1987 so I've been
working around the space for a long time
and all I hear is you got to get get
gotta get get okay what's this get all
about and what's going on well let me
start with a few discussion points that
keep coming up the first is git is only
for cloud-based development well no git
is for everyone git is for cloud for
Mainframe for everything it can store
any kind of source code you want
including your documentation it's all
going in the one source code manager it
works just fine
next thing people keep asking me about
but it can't be secure my source code is
fine it's sitting in Z pds's it's nice
and secure or secured in a library
manager that get stuff at sitting in
Cloud well it's running your business
critical applications today I mean the
front end there are business critical
cloud-based applications today so you
can't think it's not secured it's going
to be secured it's going to be a secure
environment and git can provide private
repositories so you can lock it down to
only the team access so it's secured
don't worry about that your company is
running it in a secure way to ensure
their proprietary code is well kept
and the last one get that's that's only
for a select few people but really and
truly no git is for everyone they're
using it in high school they're using it
in college everyone coming out of school
and working in cloud-based development
they're all using it today so everyone
including Mainframe developers can use
git and can work together to bring
everyone together in this environment
and the one lie mainframe's different
Mainframe is not different not when it
comes to software development there's no
reason it has to be
so we've gone through these statements
that people keep making let's talk about
the value of git to you
so the first one is you can remove waste
from the system by having your test case
automated test case alongside your
source code in the environment in git
and then it can be run for you so you
don't have to do all that manual testing
you have to do today it's all in one
place together and it can run you can
reduce those handovers because you do
the code change you get the pull
requests your code is approved and then
a pipeline handles it deploys it all the
way through the environment you don't
have to open that ticket to somebody
else
and in addition the infrastructure side
guess what you can make your
infrastructure changes those database
changes or a kicks transaction that you
need to add it's added in your git
repository and it flows into the
infrastructure for you no ticket
required isn't this wonderful all the
kinds of changes you need to make you
can make them in your own repository and
they flow and that's a value of moving
to this common git Repository
and it's visible it's visible to
everyone that needs to see it that you
can collaborate across the source code
you can work with other teams more
easily because they can see the source
it's not hidden in some place that they
can't get at
and sharing one of the problems you have
today you change your copy book or your
include you gotta send it off to the
distributed team creating that API
well with this you don't have to do that
anymore it's all in git you make that
change in that copy book or that include
and guess what automatically kicks off a
pipeline and the API is rebuilt for you
so there's no need to have to send it
off separately or go do something else
the system can handle it for you this
collaboration is provided because all
the source code is in one area all in
git we can all work together and get so
I know you're hearing all about this you
got to get get and you're not sure what
it is go play with it Go experiment it's
available everywhere you can put it on
your machine and get used to it just a
few commands and you'll be good enough
to start working so let's all get on the
get bandwagon and let's move forward and
let's collaborate together across all of
our development teams
thanks for watching if you have any
questions please reach out to your IBM
sales representative or your IBM
business partner thank you